So Joe Biden recently put out his climate
change plan and clean energy plan, and he
gave really a pretty solid speech about it.
And I think it's important to cover this stuff
because no one trumps not really doing policy.
And I do think it's important to draw a contrast
when one candidate is calling an urgent press
conference at the White House and spending
52 minutes.
I believe it was sort of a radically misreading
attacks on Joe Biden from a piece of paper,
whereas Joe Biden is actually doing policy.
Now, I know that some people in my audience
are going to be furious with me.
How dare I say that Joe Biden's climate change
proposal is pretty good.
It's not the Green New Deal.
It's not Bernie's plan.
It's not AOSIS plan or whatever the case may
be.
You know what?
Let let let's analyze it critically and understand
what have been the climate change policies
of people who have been presidents.
And by that standard, this is the most progressive
climate change proposal that if Biden is elected,
would ever be associated with a sitting president.
Of course, you can find people who have run,
who have had other proposals which we might
like better, and I'm including myself in that
list.
But if Biden gets elected, this would be the
climate change proposal most to the left of
any previous president.
And that's, I think, a really important thing
to keep in mind.
So we're taking a break from the nonsense
and the insults and the hyperbole and the
bragging of Donald Trump.
And I need to do a better job of when Joe
Biden talks about policy and puts out proposals.
I should talk about it.
Last time I did this, I went into some detail
about Joe Biden's tax plan.
It's pretty solid.
It does a number of important things that
progressives should be happy about.
Despite Biden's reputation as not being particularly
progressive.
And so I'm not going to redo the whole tax
plan story.
But Joe Biden's tax plan includes a number
of important provisions, like removing the
cap on Social Security tax above 400000 a
year in earnings.
That raises a huge amount of money from people
earning above four hundred thousand dollars
a year.
Biden would propose or proposes eliminating
the stepped up basis provision for inheritances.
I explain that last time.
I mean, this is really significant stuff in
terms of the money it would raise.
I won't redo the entire tax segment, but needless
to say, many in the audience appreciated it.
Some just came in and said it's not as progressive
as what Bernie wanted.
OK, let's now look at Joe Biden's proposal
on environmental justice and climate change
and clean energy.
Now, off the bat, there's a bunch of sort
of regular regulatory stuff in the proposal,
which I'm not going to spend a lot of time
on.
But it it does bear mentioning, which includes
Biden would establish an environmental climate
justice division in the Department of Justice.
Biden would make environmental justice a priority
within the federal government.
Biden would refresh the way that and to rehash
the way that the EPA does compliance.
That stuff deserves attention.
But I want to look at some of the specific
metrics and actions that Joe Biden has included
in his plan.
So, for example, Joe Biden includes specific
water quality improvements just to pick one
thing that's in his climate plan.
And if you look at this part of the plan,
Biden actually discusses and addresses specific
chemicals that are too much in our drinking
water.
And he does it in a way where he sees water
not only as an environmental issue, which
it is, but also as an economic issue, which
it is.
He sees water as an issue of social justice
as well.
So I think we should all be pleased that Joe
Biden is talking about water quality in his
environmental proposal in a way that shows
understanding of how water relates to race,
class, geography, economics, et cetera, et
cetera.
Remember, Joe Biden said that he would use
the Green New Deal as a framework in thinking
about what he wants to do.
And you can identify many things in his climate
change and clean energy proposals that are
almost verbatim from the Green New Deal.
Now, what's hilarious is when Biden put this
out and people identified, look, this is like
straight out of Bernie's plan.
This is straight out of green New Deal.
There were people who previously were criticizing
Biden for not being progressive enough, who
now are saying, oh, look, Biden copied stuff
from Bernie in the Green New Deal.
Shouldn't we be glad to see Biden adopting
things from Bernie Sanders and from the Green
New Deal?
Like if the concern was that Biden wasn't
taking the Green New Deal seriously enough?
Shouldn't we be glad to see elements of the
green New Deal in Biden's proposal?
And you can see these.
Components in a few different areas.
When you look at Biden's plan for retrofitting
buildings and schools in a way that will be
good for the environment but economically
stimulative.
That's straight out of the green New Deal.
A lot of the other things Biden includes in
these proposals are pretty obvious things,
but they're things that aren't being done
or or at least not done enough.
Like, for example, more seriously putting
in place subsidies and rebates when Americans
upgrade to more efficient sources of energy
and better windows and efficient appliances.
That's worthwhile government spending.
Now, two days ago, Donald Trump attacked Joe
Biden for having an ambitious goal in his
proposal.
And the goal is Biden wants to be carbon to
carbon pollution free electricity by 2035,
meaning by 2035.
Biden wants the country to be generating electricity
from sources that do not pollute.
From the standpoint of carbon, that's a huge
task.
But if the criticism here is that Biden is
too ambitious on climate and clean energy,
I'll take it.
I mean, look at the Trump administration that's
going in the opposite direction, wanting to
loosen emission standards for vehicles, wanting
to rehabilitate coal.
We've had that for three and a half years.
I'll take an overly ambitious proposal from
Joe Biden any day.
And importantly, one of the things I like
about this proposal, again, is Joe Biden is
connecting energy issues to economics and
social justice and race.
And he's connecting environmental issues to
all of those same areas.
So, for example, when Biden talks about his
proposal that by 2035 he wants to be generate
generating electricity from sources that don't
pollute.
From the standpoint of carbon, he specifically
says, let's do this by creating jobs with
this green energy shift where we will look
to HPC, use historically black colleges and
universities for training and hiring, et cetera.
Just one example.
So where I'm ending up on this is if you know
something about Joe Biden, you actually shouldn't
be surprised that his climate and energy proposal
is very solid.
Joe Biden actually wrote the first climate
change mitigation bill in 1987.
He tried it in 86 and it went nowhere in 87.
It was signed into law by President Ronald
Reagan.
And it's particularly disappointing to see
some leftists who are framing Joe Biden as
kind of like reluctantly dealing with climate
change, sort of.
Biden actually has been on this for more than
30 years.
There's lots of areas where Biden has not
really been great unless you look at the last
10 years.
If you look 25 years ago, there's areas where
Biden was not so good.
Biden has been on climate for more than 30
years.
He said he would use the Green New Deal as
a framework for his proposal, and he did.
So let's criticize Biden where it's warranted.
Let's criticize Biden, where the proposals
he makes don't go far enough.
And I'll be digging into that in more detail
probably next week.
But know the pretending that Biden is just
a center right guy on every issue, including
climate.
It's wrong.
And the fact that Biden put out this proposal
reinforces the importance of trying to take
the Senate so that we can maybe actually get
some of these things on Joe Biden's desk,
put him in a position to have to sign stuff
into law rather than having this long list
of proposals that will never see the light
of day because Democrats don't control the
Senate anyway.
So for me, it's reinforcing.
Hey, Biden's actually been pretty good on
climate for a long time.
And number two, importantly, the importance
of the Senate to actually get some of this
stuff in front of Joe Biden
to sign.